it's a when did you see this Stephen
Thompson thing with Darren toe where he
wants them to outlaw that sidekick to
the knee no I didn't see that
well apparently his knee got really
[ __ ] up in the dare until fight you
know woody what do you think about that
side Lake to the knee that everyone's do
not even the oblique kick just a front
leg side kick to the knee the same way
Yoel Romero used it Robert Whittaker
[ __ ] up his knee in the first fight
right and then Whitaker used it on
Romero like right away because that can
fight you have to [ __ ] up his name hmm
I think it's a legitimate kick yeah it's
a legitimate one hundred percent kick it
allows the smaller weaker guy to hurt
the bigger stronger guy well in the case
of dare until it allows the bigger
stronger guys
yes hurt the other big if it works for
the smaller guy who works for the bigger
guy Yeah right it's legit it's I think
so too it's a legit technique you have
to repair for yeah exactly you're
standing in a way that existing sideways
mm-hmm they're harder to punch they're
easier to kick
so you're saying look I want to stand in
this way where I'm harder to punch but I
don't want you to kick me mm-hmm so if I
stand square I'm more susceptible to
back kick more supple two punches but
less susceptible to leg kicks or the
oblique kick or the side kick to the
knee or what not mm-hmm now I'm not
saying to you don't punch me because I'm
more vulnerable this way so whatever
your vulnerability is you chose that
vulnerability by standing sideways
why don't I stand sideways because they
know they're gonna get chopped to the
leg right they're always fighting good
kickers they're always fighting amazing
kickers when you go to Thailand that guy
may be a good puncher but he's for sure
a great kicker like you're not gonna run
into a guy who doesn't know how to kick
they all know how to kick knee and elbow
and some of them know how to punch
really really well also so they stand in
a way mota has developed in a way that's
very anti kick Antony anti elbow and
it's not as defensive to the punches so
if I want to stand if I want to avoid
punches I'll stand more bladed let's say
I'm fighting out like a BJ Penn who's
very heavy-handed and more of a puncher
it doesn't kick much well I'm gonna
stand bladed like you see what George
Will made him drop one hand why so he
can use his jab from from down to up
right because it's faster has a greater
reach and it's harder to counter whereas
if you would have stood more Square and
MoIT I would have been useless because
Vijay doesn't kick mm-hmm but then you'd
be more open to punches right so the way
you're
standing the way a wonderboy standing
that the antagonists to that the dad -
Doh - that is that kick so how could you
stand that way just switch the way
you're standing and now it okay now you
you're more open to punches but that's
adaptation that's what fighting is about
yeah it's rock paper scissors if I use
rock I don't I don't
outlaw paper I don't say everybody hey
nobody is allowed to use paper no but
that's that - Doh - what you're doing
yeah and when the ties fight they have
that very light front leg when you
wouldn't prevent that front leg side
kick to the knee exactly because they're
always there it's just gonna go
backwards anyway to stand that way
they're standing that way at a cost yeah
punches and also the cost they don't
have the ability to use that movement
that flattering front leg movement the
way that wonderboy does - wonderboy is
the master of the front leg like he's
the best at standing completely side
kick the when he fought Johny Hendricks
good example he threw a side kick to the
body
Hendricks stood there and then he went
to roundhouse kick my face with the same
leg masterpiece and and Hendricks he
could see was like [ __ ] like what is
this guy doing yeah there's like foam
okay back oh [ __ ] like he thought like
yeah you got me with that but that's not
a big deal and then pop he gets
roundhouse kicked in the face that was a
masterful performance yeah yeah I was
one of his best for sure was incredible
what just shows you the difference
between a guy who is you know just
trying to like kind of plot in with the
limited movement and a guy like wonder
boy who's just one of the most difficult
guys to sort of pin down yeah incredible
yeah his style is very unique and I'm
fascinating with him and I'm really
fascinated right now with Michael venom
page been watching it do you see his pro
boxing fights no I didn't see right now
he's a catcher somewhere I saw one yeah
he's a can crusher he's fighting these
guys then they're setting him up for
these yeah spectacular knockouts right
but it's still that blitz point karate
style that Raymond Daniels has a lot of
these guys having Raymond's obviously
adapted very well for kickboxing I've
seen Raymond quite a bit he's a beast
you gotta get him on the show when he
says - yeah I have to connect you - okay
he's amazing yeah we talked a little bit
in the past about perhaps doing
something on Twitter he knocks guys out
in about 90 seconds on a regular basis
and how does he do it he does it with
kick he's the master at finding a place
for the back kick you don't want to get
hit with his back kick like I know you
got an incredible back kick I bet you
some more powerful than his okay but
I'll tell you one thing he will fit that
back kick everywhere everywhere and I'll
do it in a way you won't see it coming
and it's gonna hurt so much more yeah he
rarely knocks guys out with his hands he
does surprise guys with his hands every
so often but that back kick you don't
want to be there well he seems like he's
getting better with his hands yes yes
hands are improving but he trains a lot
yeah trees a lot that guy I'm sure I
mean he's he's still at it and he's what
35 36 now I would say around there that
one was it what's his name um bang was
that the guy he knocked out with that
touch front leg side kick and then the
spinning back kick to the face
videogames unbelievable he just jumps up
top pop and the second kick yeah that's
a standard kick it is you know for for
Raymond damn he doesn't the best I've
ever seen personally no no one better
you know we got to go back to like Rick
the jet Rufus
you know when he fought that that really
classic fight where he fought that Thai
fighter and got his legs chopped down
and everybody was like oh [ __ ] people
really got to understand the Muay Thai
Muay Thai but he hit back out that same
kick that front legs and kick him and
spun in the air and him with the turning
side kick in the face yeah yeah man
that's I love watching that point karate
style that blitz style I love it I love
watching that enter into MMA because I
used to spar with a lot of those guys
and it's [ __ ] hard to deal with those
guys that are really good at that that
that fast sprint out you blitz and when
you do that and then you also have
takedown defense and Muay Thai skills
and Jiu Jitsu is like [ __ ] man that's so
let's a lethal skill to have mmm I love
I love doing boxing Muay Thai karate
Taekwondo I love I love blending at all
I believe all of yours right here I mean
come on man this is [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
the way does it - he just hops up
touches you with the front leg pains and
the second one and look he looks down
like he's in a [ __ ] video game I mean
that is crazy
that this guy is pulling that off that
was the one he was in glory
look at this tap oh come on man who the
[ __ ] does that
and he does that all the time that's not
like a one-off no no he could do that
all day yeah I mean there's a lot of
those karate guys that have that skill
set they can do it like you know those
breaking demonstrations where they're
holed up paths they'll do 360 wheel
kicks and brake pads and I mean there's
there's some legitimate karate and
traditional martial arts techniques that
are finding their way into MMA
absolutely just have to know how to use
it yeah and just because a karate guy
got beat up by a grappler doesn't mean
all the karate he's trained it's not
good exactly these laws need to learn
how to grapple exactly he's like I stay
on his feeding this learn how to grapple
he needs to learn to set that kick up in
a way because I think is if you're
always fighting another karate guy and
then you fight a boxer the boxers
behavior is just different you have to
get it's like what we're saying before
you have to get used to it and then all
of a sudden you saw the same movie a
hundred times you know how to deal with
it you know it's like you watch the same
movie over and over again you start you
start predicting what the scene is gonna
be you're not caught by surprise when
you're caught by surprise you're done
right you never done jujitsu before and
I'm doing an armbar basic armbar you're
getting caught with it mmm you know
that's why I believe you got to know
everything out there but you got to
specialize